[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the AIY
introductory session.
How's everybody for I/O so far?
Everybody had a
good lunch today?
Yes.
OK.
As you can see on the screen,
the name of this session
is called Introduction to AIY.
But what is AIY?
AIY is a new line
of product Google
makes for developers like you,
makers all around the world,
to make applications for
artificial intelligence
by yourself.
That's the name of AIY,
where that came from.
Today joining with
me, my colleagues
in developer relations.
My name is Bill Luan.
I have Dushyantsinh
Sebastian joining me.
We will give you a full
introduction of the current AIY
product line.
So before we start, let me
introduce my colleagues.
So, Dushyantsinh.
DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA:
Thank you, Bill.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Dushyantsinh.
I'm part of Google's developer
relations team in India.
I'm really excited here to show
you some amazing demos on AIY
script.
But before we start,
I'll invite Sebastian
to give you a quick
overview of what is AIY
and set the context
for this talk.
SEBASTIAN TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT:
Thank you, Dushyantsinh.
So thank you very much
for being here in person
or watching this on YouTube.
I'm Sebastian, with this
very complicated last name.
I've joined Google
quite recently, just
about 11 years ago.
And with my teams, what
we do around the world,
especially in
emerging markets, is
we help developers and
start-ups build better
mobile and web applications.
Today I want to talk
to you about AIY.
But before this,
let's talk about DIY--
do it yourself.
So do you know what this is?
It's not a UFO.
It's actually a
musical instrument
which makes very nice sounds.
But no, it was not invented
in prehistoric times.
It was actually created in
the year 2000 in Switzerland.
Switzerland is
actually the country
where I'm officially based.
Well, that is when I'm not in
one of the other UFOs, which
we call planes, because I travel
quite a bit to visit my teams.
Do you know what this is also?
It's a window into DIY culture.
Let me take you through a very
brief history of humankind's
appetite for DIY.
And if you read
the book "Sapiens--
A Brief History of
Humankind," you'll
know what I'm talking about.
Our human ancestors were
already building tools,
as probably you know--
weapons, instruments
using stone and wood.
Now if we skip a few
generations of humans,
we're still using
wood to create things.
This is one of my brothers,
Mattias, and my sister,
Lydia, some 30 years ago.
And I'm sure you
or your siblings
did the same thing-- tinkering
with stuff or everything
you could lay your hands on.
Now let's fast forward
to the, what I call,
the electronics age.
Do you remember in the '90s
how desktop computers--
I'm not even talking
about laptops--
but desktops were so expensive?
Who among you, show
of hands maybe, to see
who built computers
with spare parts?
Yeah.
I did that too.
Quite a few of you, and
I'm not the only one
who's too old for this.
On this animated
image you can see
how I've used an overhead
projector and a dismantled LCD
screen to build a cheap
homemade video projector.
But then obviously
my mom got annoyed
because all the electronics were
everywhere in the living room.
So she said, go outside,
you need some fresh air.
OK, so I went
outside, and that's
me reusing garbage bags--
one dollar of garbage bags
to build a solar balloon.
It can almost lift
me up, not quite,
but I'll get there one day.
But the appeal of electronics
was just too strong,
so my siblings and I got back
inside and one of my brothers--
the other one, Florian--
started tinkering with 3D
printers, homemade 3D printers.
This is my other brother,
the one on the right.
On the left is actually
a photo in the museum.
As I said, DIY is in our DNA
from very, very early on.
It's also in Google's DNA.
Four years ago, you may
remember a Google engineer from
the Paris office--
and I mentioned Paris
because I'm actually French--
and this engineer came here
at I/O to show the VR platform
he had built using cardboard
during his 20% innovation time.
Since then, this has
become, two years ago,
what we call the Daydream
VR platform at Google.
Here's what's interesting now.
The maker culture is
all about hardware
on one side, physical objects,
and on the other hand,
software-- this
combination of DIY culture
with a hacker culture.
You may have heard of
Maker Faire, since 2006.
You may have maker spaces
around you, and if there's
none in your city where you
live, then why don't you start
one of these maker spaces?
The great thing about
this maker culture
is that you learn through
doing with your hands.
You make mistakes, so what?
Doesn't matter.
That's a very good way to
learn, to try new things
and learn from each other,
figure out new applications
that you can create
with that technology.
It doesn't matter
what your background.
In fact, it's even better
when you can mix and match
different domains to find new
applications of the technology.
Now let's take a
look at what has
happened in the past few years.
You now have micro-controllers,
like Raspberry Pi.
The cloud has become cheaper.
Lithium batteries
have become cheaper.
Did you know that lithium
battery, their cost,
has decreased by 80% over
the past eight years?
And I'm sure you've heard about
AI, artificial intelligence,
especially since
yesterday, and concepts
like machine learning,
deep neural networks.
Sounds complicated, right?
It doesn't have to be.
And this is why, with
AIY, do it yourself
AI, artificial intelligence,
that we introduced last year,
you can have fun.
Because the idea of
this maker culture
is, before anything
else, to have
fun using, in this case,
artificial intelligence.
We want to put AI
literally in your hands
so that you can
solve real problems.
Our AIY kits are open source.
They combine
hardware and software
and they integrate AI directly
on the device themselves.
The essence, as I
mentioned previously,
is to keep it low cost using
readily available components
that you can find almost
anywhere on the planet.
And the kits are very
easy to assemble.
Dushyantsinh, how
long does it take
to assemble one of these kits?
DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA:
15 to 30 minutes.
SEBASTIAN TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT:
15, 30 minutes.
OK, let's say one
hour because my mom is
going to say I'm very clumsy.
Thank you, mom.
I know she's watching.
So let's say not more than an
hour to assemble these kits.
Dushyantsinh and Bill right
after, in just a few minutes,
will demo some of
these kits to show
what you can do with them-- so
the Voice Kit and the Vision
Kit.
But stay with us.
In the coming weeks
and the coming months,
there'll be more to
announce in that space.
Now let's take a look and
I'll finish off with this.
What some of you
have already created,
in this example I'm going to
show you in just a few seconds,
a 16-year-old with no
programming experience
has managed to come up with
the following use case.
Let's play the video for
just about 20 seconds.
LAWRENCE: Shop for New
York Yankees baseball hats.
So what's actually
happening now?
VOICE KIT: Done.
LAWRENCE: So she just
said done, right?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
LAWRENCE: OK.
SPEAKER: So what
actually happened
was that, when it
said done, it's
just sent links to my email
after finding it on eBay.
So it'll find results online,
send links in an email to me,
and I'm going to receive
those so then I can quickly
click and buy something.
SEBASTIAN
TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT: So what
happened here with Lawrence
and the high school kid
was shopping for a product.
I don't know if you heard
that at the beginning--
"I'm shopping for
some baseball caps,"
and it was searching
on eBay for results,
which were emailed right after
when the device was done.
So let me take you
through the code.
It's just, if you
heard at the beginning,
"I'm shopping for
some baseball caps.
And it was searching
on eBay for results,
which [AUDIO OUT] were
emailed right after, when
the device had done.
So let me take you
[AUDIO OUT] through the code.
It's just [AUDIO OUT] if you
heard it at the beginning.
I'm shopping for some
baseball [AUDIO OUT]
and we're searching on eBay
for results [AUDIO OUT]
were emailed right after
[AUDIO OUT] through the code.
It's just [AUDIO OUT] if you
heard it at the beginning.
I'm shopping for some
baseball cap [AUDIO OUT]
through the code it's just
[AUDIO OUT] if you heard it
at the beginning.
I'm shopping for some
baseball cap [AUDIO OUT]
You may remember in the
video that all the results
are sent over email.
Here's the code.
We're going to go through
each result, the first three
lines of the code up there, and
format all this in an email.
You can recognize, even if
you're not an experienced
programmer, something like,
from, to, subject line.
That's it.
Nothing more.
The last thing we
do is just connect
to the server, the email
server, and just send the email,
and get the device
to say, "done."
That's it.
There's nothing more.
You can literally copy
and paste that code.
It will work.
Now it's your turn to
do things with AIY.
And if you're not
inspired enough,
I'll have Dushyantsinh
now to come on stage
to do a demo with a voice kit.
So thank you very
much for listening,
and welcome Dushyantsinh
back on stage.
DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA:
Thank you, Sebastian.
My name is Dushyantsinh and I'm
part of a developer relations
teams at Google.
And like everybody, we all are
excited about the possibility
of AI has in front
of us, correct?
This only becomes more
meaningful and more impactful
when all of us
can have an access
to this wonderful platform.
At Google, we have been sharing
our work and advancement
in the field of
artificial intelligence
by building products, sharing
to our research papers,
and now with the
AIY kits, we are
taking to even more people
in a more playful way,
yet it is strong
enough for you to solve
some really good problems.
So let's see how we can
solve some of those things.
And when we are thinking
about this kit together,
your thinking, what
makes sense, what
would be right way of putting
this in front of people?
And, of course, voice
was one of the things
that was very evident.
We all like talking.
Imagine if we have a
power of playing around
with a voice, how
fun it would be.
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned
in the keynote
yesterday about WaveNet, how
you can create different voices.
So in this demo, I'm
just going to talk
about the capabilities
of AIY kit
with Cloud Speech API
and Google Assistant API
but, of course, there's
much more than this.
So the Voice Kit was launched
sometime mid-last year,
if I'm not wrong, and it
had got a lot of attention.
The Voice Kit basically has
a combination of few software
and some of the hardware there.
It was marketed along with
Raspberry Pi Foundation
to see what are the feedback we
can get from the existing maker
community and try to
improve our offering.
We launched the second
version of Voice Kit
sometime in January to
incorporate all those feedbacks
and make it all in a
one box component kit.
So that's what you get today.
If you go to AIY website
and look at Voice Kit,
this is what you'll
probably find there.
But what does the kit contain?
From a hardware point of view
it has Raspberry Pi Zero,
it has Voice Bonnet,
which is basically
a piece of hardware which
does audio processing for you,
and the Voice Bonnet has
different components.
It has a mic, it has a codec,
a micro-controller, general
all-purpose input output,
and an arcade button
to basically give you
visual indication of what's
happening with your Voice
Kit at any point of time.
And from a software
point of view,
it basically runs
on Raspbian Linux.
It uses Google Assistant API
and uses Cloud Speech API.
But of course, you could do
a bunch of things with that.
This is just scratching the
surface of the Voice Kit.
So how can you get started?
Very straightforward.
Think of it as a
three-step process.
Step one is in terms
of assembling the kit,
step two is setting
up your device,
and step 3 is, now that
you have set up everything,
you could go ahead and build
some of solution by yourself.
So if you open the kit,
this is what it looks like.
First thing, ensure you have
all the right components.
You have a cardboard, all
the different hardwares that
is mentioned on the website.
Just verify that you have all
those components ready with you
before you start
assembling together.
Once you verify, the next
step what you need to do
is build an engine.
Think of it as building a car.
You're building an engine,
so putting Raspberry Pi
and your Voice Bonnet together.
Once you put the
engine together,
then now you're
building a chassis.
So it's kind of a
structure for your car,
or structure for your Voice Kit.
So you basically
take the cardboard
and get of give it a
structure of a speaker.
Once you build the
cardboard, then you
put the engine inside it.
You put the Raspberry Pi
and Voice Bonnet inside it.
That's it.
It's super easy, super fun.
For me, when I tried first
time it took something
around 15 to 20 minutes.
But I'm sure you
guys are much, much
advanced than me and you could
try to get it even faster.
The key here is not
to do fast, but do it
in a nice fun way out of it.
So, yeah.
That's it.
You assembled your Voice Kit.
Step two is basically
set up your device.
At this point of
time, what you want
to do is that now
I have my device,
or my Voice Kit is more or
less in a nice shape and form,
let me give a voice to it.
Let me see if everything
is working fine.
So I have a already
built Voice Kit
here, and I'm going to
switch back to my Voice Kit
and see if everything
is working fine there.
So before you start, you want to
ensure that you have everything
running for you.
So things like, let's say
you're connected to network--
this could be either a wired
network or a wireless network
or, if you're tethering
from your phone,
essentially you have
some sort of connection
because a Voice Kit needs
to be connected to internet.
It's using Google
Assistant and Speech
API for recognition purposes.
Let me see if I'm online.
Good.
Looks like I'm all set from
an internet point of view.
Let's see if my audio
is working fine,
if the kit's audio
is working fine.
VOICE KIT: Front, center.
DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Seems OK.
Let me see if it
recognizes my voice.
Testing.
One, two, three.
VOICE KIT: Testing.
DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA:
Seems to be OK.
So now I'm almost set.
The good thing is that
Voice Kit comes with some
of the pre-built demos as well.
It's good to see if those are
also looking fine before you
start building yourself.
So if you go to the Pi
directory and look at Pi10 voice
examples, which is here.
And I'm just going to
try this library demo.
Hey, Google, what's
the time right now?
VOICE KIT: It's 1:50.
DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Thank you.
So you could try
a bunch of things.
What I was doing is
that I was just testing
if things are working fine.
Now, of course you could,
at this point in time ask,
a bunch of other questions.
Now, things seem to be OK.
Let me see if I can
build something or not.
Let me go back to presentation.
Can we go back to slides?
Yeah.
So it's always good to see
if the device is working fine
before you start
building by yourself.
I have built a typical
shopping experience.
Hopefully it should work
fine, but let's see,
given the set up was not
really up to the mark,
but let's give it one more shot.
Can we switch to demo?
So Sebastian did show, he
was showing the code which
was mostly about giving a
command to a Voice Assistant
saying, shop for something.
And then it was trying
to identify a text,
and it was calling
one of the API, which
was from eBay I
believe, and then
trying to basically fed
some some of the result
and send it as an email.
I've tried to mimic
similar behavior.
And let's see if the
demo codes are with me.
So what I'm doing at
this point of time,
I'm just going to maybe
shop for something.
Because Mother's
Day is coming up
and I won't be in time
for it, and I want
to send something to my mom.
And I was thinking, what
could be an interesting thing?
Apparently the smartwatches
is a big thing,
so I thought, OK, maybe let
me give her a smartwatch.
So let's see if I can find a
smartwatch using my Voice Kit.
Hey, Google.
Shop for a smartwatch.
Cool.
VOICE KIT: Done.
DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: So if
you look at what it did,
it basically recognized
my voice or my command,
and connected with the
particular service,
and displayed some of those
smartwatches available for me
to purchase.
And now, at this point of
time, I could take this output
and either send an email, like
what Sebastian was mentioning
or, if I have a
smart display device,
I could basically post it there,
give a nice visual of list,
like these are
some of the things,
or I could engage in a
little bit more conversation
with that.
Can we move back to slides?
But there's tons of things
you could do that, correct?
What I was trying
to emphasize here
is that there's a lot of
things possible with the device
that you could play
around with it.
You could also not just look
at the software as a one
side of it, but you could
also experiment with some
of the things in the hardware.
So we have seen people
taking the old toys
and putting the Voice Kits
or some of the other AIY kits
into it and revive the bodies
or bring life to those toys.
We have seen people customize
shelves for Voice Kits.
There are people who have
done device remix, so
giving voice and vision to
a Roomba vacuum cleaner.
So you could tell
them, OK, don't
go to this side of the house,
but go to the different side
of house section.
Or you could create completely
custom voice actions.
So tons of things is possible.
If you want to know
more about what is that,
you could follow us on
Instagram, or Twitter,
or follow the discussion on
Reddit with AIY projects.
With that, I'll invite Bill
to know more about what's
happening on Vision Kit.
BILL LUAN: Thank you.
Thank you, Dushyantsinh.
[INAUDIBLE] OK?
All right.
Let me continue with the second
product line in the AIY product
family which, as you can
see, is the Vision Kit.
The Vision Kit is a
relatively new product,
and it's just been
released end of last year,
and we've had a
new version update
the first quarter of this year.
So the latest version is
1.1 where, as you can see,
launched in December
of last year.
It has the latest Raspberry
Pi Zero and the WH,
the header is
soldered on the board.
So it doesn't have the
problem in the early version
that you have to solder
the pins yourself.
It's much easier.
It comes with the Raspberry
Pi camera version 2,
and Google-made Vision
Bonnet circuit board,
and that's where all the
software, hardware, artificial
intelligence, where Google
put it into the product.
It's on the Vision [INAUDIBLE].
The most unique things of
this particular product,
it doesn't require you
to connect to internet.
You can work with the
vision recognition software
on the box by itself alone.
So, before we start, let's go
through the list of materials
that Dushyantsinh did for the
Voice Kit-- a similar thing.
In terms of the
hardware, as I mentioned,
it has the latest Raspberry
Pi Zero board and a camera,
and Google produced
this Vision Bonnet.
This Vision Bonnet circuit
board contains the Intel vision
recognition processor,
which has all the computing
power to help you do
the vision recognition.
In addition to that, it
has the camera support
and it has the connections
to the Raspberry Pi cable
connector.
It also has the general
purpose input output,
so-called GPIO
connector allows you
to do more things, which
I'm going to cover shortly.
And also, it has the
crypto chip on board
to help you to encrypt the
signals to add more securities
in terms of the application.
Then on the software side-- oh,
it also has the button as well
as the cardboard form, allow
you to fold in to the device.
On the software side, the
operating system is the same.
It runs on the Linux
Raspbian operating system,
will include a TensorFlow,
the so-called Inception
and MobileNet software,
a sound device,
which allow you to build AI
models to work with this device
to do applications in AI.
It has the built-in software
for facial recognition
as well as general
object recognition.
So all this software is on
the device, ready to use.
And in terms of
its component, let
me get into a bit more
detail because this
is a relatively new product.
On the hardware level
at the bottom, which
is the Raspberry Pi Zero
with the head soldered on,
as I said, the Raspberry Pi
Zero has the built-in Wi-Fi
and Bluetooth support.
So you can connect
to the internet
if you want without a cable with
Wi-Fi connected to internet.
It has a GPIO connection, which
allows it to connect directly
with a flex cable to the Google
Vision Bonnet circuit board.
That circuit board, with
additional flex cable,
connects to Pi camera as well
as the additional accessories,
like the LED, and the push
button, and the buzzer.
There's a piece of
buzzer on the device
that, as your
application necessary,
you can have it generate sound.
Then on the software side, it
runs on the same Linux Raspbian
operating system,
and the program
runs all in Python code, so
it has the Python interpreter
on top of that.
And at Google, the
software we put together
contains three different
modules, if you will,
in terms of division process.
The first is the
TensorFlow module
that does the vision inception.
Secondly, it has
the facial detection
software, and the third, it has
the object detection software.
So with these software on board
and with all these hardware,
and you, through the API
course, write your applications
interface with these components.
So this is how everything
is put together.
And then let me go
through the same process
Dushyantsinh mentioned in
terms of the Voice Kit.
So first is, you assemble it.
In terms of assemble,
very similar.
You bought the box, it has these
parts, cardboard or whatever.
As you can see on the screen,
in terms of the process,
building is relatively easy.
You basically hook up the
Raspberry Pi with the Vision
Bonnet-- a cable with that
orange-colored cable--
hook them together, stack
them together, and then
fold the cardboard box, insert
this module into the middle--
almost like you put
the engine in a car,
as Dushyantsinh mentioned-- hook
up the button, and that's it.
The first time I built this,
about 40-something minutes.
Second time I built it, it
took me only 20 minutes.
So it's very simple.
In fact, I have a
plug for myself.
I made a video tutorial of
how to assemble it on YouTube.
So for those of you who don't
want to read the instructions,
you can watch the video.
But it's very simple, very easy.
OK.
All right.
So to assemble that,
congratulations.
In less than an hour,
you'll be able to just build
a device like that.
OK in terms of set-up,
this is very simple.
As I said, this
does not necessarily
need to hook up to internet.
So the connection, all you
need is just a power supply.
A power supply connects to
it and you're ready to go.
And because of the facial
recognition software
we built into the
device, after you power
it up it will automatically run
the facial detection software.
So right now, on the desk,
I have this Vision Bonnet
with me.
And as you can see, the
top LED blue light--
the button-- is lighted up.
Now if I point this to
my face, as you can see,
the blue light indicating the
camera is capturing my face.
If I show it to the camera with
a smiley face, a happy face,
the light color of the
LCD will change to yellow.
And if I'm showing a frowning
face, it will go back to blue.
So let me demonstrate this.
Can everybody see?
Right?
It changes the color.
Now let me say, this is
not some kind of a magic.
It is AI at working.
So what happened, it is a
software inside with the AI
TensorFlow model with the
facial recognition-- actually,
I'm going to get
to it in a minute--
to make a facial recognition
software just like that.
So there's not much of a set up.
Just power it on,
hook up the power,
and you can do
facial recognition.
This demo is called
Joy Detection.
It's a part of a product
we ship with the device.
All right.
So assembly very easy,
set-up, it's very easy.
How to make your own solutions.
There's a lot of
software you could
do, and let me do another demo.
So please switch the screen to
the output of my other device.
So as you can see right now, I'm
running the Raspbian software
operating system and there's
a window showing the software.
Let me, by starting
a simple demo, which
is the object classification.
So I'm going to start
with demo, and as you
will see on the screen,
on the right hand
side it will have the camera,
the video image coming captured
by the camera.
And on the table I have
a apple, and a banana,
and also a Coke can.
This is some random objects
that I put together.
Now as you can see, on the
left side of the screen,
there's the output
stream out starting
putting on the screen, which
is by the object classification
software that we
put on the device.
Now, I'm going to explain
all of that in a minute,
but first let me do a demo.
Let me just point
this to banana.
And you should see on the
left hand of the screen,
it will say it
detects this object--
a banana, I hope.
Now if I point to
an apple, not only
it will recognize
it's an apple, in fact
it should say Granny Smith.
It actually recognizes
the type of the apple.
And I already tried earlier,
I pointed this Coca-Cola can.
I don't know what it will say,
but earlier it was telling me
it thinks it's a punching bag.
Well, lots of punching bags is
red color, it looks like this.
So let me stop the
application and let me make
this window a little bigger.
And as you can see on the left
side, the first column number,
it is the object recognition.
It recognizes it.
It says it's a banana.
The number after that is the
so-called confidence score--
how confident the AI thinks
this is a banana, or similarly,
to an apple, which is
a Granny Smith apple.
So this confidence level tells
you, the recognition part, will
it think it truly is
the object it detects.
These numbers, these kind of
feedback from their software,
you can use to make a
lot of applications.
Let's switch back to the slides.
So this image on the
screen, as you can see,
very similar, right?
It recognized the object
along with a confidence score.
You can use this number to help
you design your applications.
So exactly what can you
do with a Vision Kit?
Well, number one, as I
said, you can see it already
does the object detection.
And it has the
facial detection--
these are software built into
it, and through the API course
you can leverage this.
It has the automatically to be
able to taking photos, videos,
and send an output
to your application.
It has the image
classification, which you just
saw, be able to tell
apple and banana,
and a whole bunch
of other stuff.
But most importantly, as
the Joy Detect demonstrate,
you can run your own AI
machine learning software
in this device by building
your own customized TensorFlow
model.
Now some of you may be
thinking, how do I do that?
It's a bit confusing in terms
of building a TensorFlow model.
That's very powerful stuff.
How do you do that?
All right.
So let me introduce
to you the process
of how do you do your
customized model.
So first of all, the
first number one--
every machine learning model
you build in TensorFlow,
you're building
a model to train.
So specify and train your
own model is the first step.
And the second, just like
any other TensorFlow model,
you get the end results, you
do a so-called export model
to a so-called frozen graph.
Any model, you can
generate frozen graph.
But a frozen graph
has its own format.
That format is not understood
by the Vision Bonnet hardware.
So somehow, we need
to make a match,
and that match is
then the next step,
is the so-called compiler.
Google provides this so-called
Bonnet Model Compiler.
You take the frozen
graph binary code
and run the compiling
through the compiled code.
You generate a so-called your
own customized computer graph.
So the other fact-wise
is, in end result,
you're going through
with these three steps,
you have a binary file.
That file defines your
machine learning model.
Then on the hardware side of
course, we have Raspberry Pi,
we have Vision Bonnet.
Raspberry Pi has
a Python program.
You use the API course, you
send this computer graph,
if you will, to
the Vision Bonnet.
So the next step,
you write some code--
you can look at our tutorials
and example models--
code in a model
function, basically it
sends this computer graph
into the Vision Bonnet.
In this particular
case, the computer graph
and Vision Bonnet match.
They understood what's going on.
And then you have a
camera coming and stream
all the inputs.
Those inputs are coming
as a binary number,
but because of these
computer graphs,
we arrange these inputs into
whatever the machine learning
tensors, which
basically is a bunch
of multi-dimensional arrays.
So now, next step
is you need to match
this tensor, bunch of arrays,
to the image with your model.
And this is what we
call do this computing.
Basically the step is
you write a program,
you have this Vision
Bonnet hardware,
it does the calculation,
and will send the signal
to the output.
And here's the code.
How do you define your face
object, as you can see?
The face object was defined
with the bounding box, the face
score, and the joy score.
You write a arguments
code like that
and this is your structure.
You send it as a structure
and say, in my model,
I need this to have four.
And these four numbers match
with my machine learning model.
And finally, in your
application code
you just say, let me get
results from this tensor
whether the joy scores,
the face score, whatever,
and you take that
into your end result.
And you can make a
decision and say,
the score is based on some
number above some number,
change my color light.
So this is exactly
what you do in terms
of using your own
machine learning model
with the Vision Kit.
All right.
So with that, let's talk
about extending our project.
We talked about software,
but how about hardware?
On the AIY board, there's the
red circle area I pointed out.
It has additional GPI pins.
With those pins, you
can control output--
turn on the lights,
turn on the fans,
send out making some noise,
whatever you could do.
So with these things, you
could expand your project
and, with that control on board,
you can do a lot more things.
So hardware-wise, is a maker
which can do the most things.
All right.
So we've gone through all these.
We talked about the
assemble, how do you set up,
and how do you do
your own things.
And most importantly, I
want to say, to use AIY,
the power of AIY
really is connected
to many of the services
Google provides, like Google
Assistant, like TensorFlow.
You want to leverage all this
power of service behind you.
And AIY, we are part of a
global open source community.
We publish this on GitHub,
we work with Raspberry Pi
Foundation, we
work with Hackster,
so immerse yourself
with the online maker
communities around the world.
And this is the part of the
fun of building makers--
AIY.
I want to mention, take this
opportunity to tell everybody,
for the audience here,
those of you from the US,
you could join a contest
going on right now organized
by Hackster with the Ministry
of Education in China,
is so-called the Young
US-China Makers Contest.
The winners will get a
all-expense paid trip to China.
So those of you in the room,
you are American makers,
please join this contest.
And more details on
Hackster's website.
All right.
The key takeaway
from our talk today,
what Sebastian and
Dushyantsinh mention
in their part of the talk,
and mine, the key takeaway is,
resource-wise, the
global AIY website
is this address--
aiyprojects.withgoogle.com.
The kits can be
purchased right now
at the Target store in the US.
And also, next weekend
in the Bay Area
there is a Maker's Faire.
Those of you who are in the
area joining the Maker's Faire,
you can get the kits
from the Maker's Faire.
Learning using Raspberry
Pi using Python programming
is part of the
thing that you need
to get yourself involved to
expand your applications,
and using TensorFlow
machine learning model
to really build the power
of AI into applications.
And that's the power of AIY.
And finally, to summary, and
I would say call to action,
the things you guys could do--
everyone could do-- getting our
kits and start building, have
a lot of fun, of course, and
learning many Google services.
At Google I/O we have sessions
on Google Cloud, on Google
Assistant, on TensorFlow.
Please join in the learning
of those knowledge and skills
and get a lot of different
sensors, controls.
Hook up to the GPIO
ports on those devices.
You can build a lot
of fun applications
and leverage your AI capability.
And lastly, joining
online communities.
We will very soon publish
a global AIY model exchange
and put your
application on that,
share your knowledge with the
global developer communities.
So with that, along with
Sebastian and Dushyantsinh,
we want to thank you for coming,
joining our session today.
Start your AIY journey today.
Thank you very much.